un appel masqué à 7h décrocher c'est
peut-être quelqu'un d'important Raphaël
Nadal Raphaël est intéressé par votre
chalet et voudrait visiter avant de
l'acheter donc il n'a pas acheté c'est
pas Ibis ça dans mon challenge c'est bon
j'ai réussi à me libérer opération
Bioman lancée
la vue mes potes mes potes la vue
la tête
d'atterrissage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le différent devrait être réglé par une
alcoolympiade
mais il y en a marre de vos conneries
madame la mère ça ne se reproduira plus
c'est fini
pour voyage les gars
on a bien rigolé monsieur mais
maintenant de décrocher moi
[Musique]
comment ça se passe avec Nadal très très
sympa
est en freestyle dans le chalet on était
aussi défoncé que ça
alors qu'il est je suis sûr qu'il est en
train de prier
[Musique]